hello everybody and welcome I am mark
camlet Provost of Carnegie Mellon and
thank you very much for coming to my
introduction gives me a pleasure to
actually welcome you for what we're here
for which is the IBM centennial
celebration lecture and we are very
delighted to have two longtime friends
of Carnegie Mellon from IBM Wayne Volta
who is a CMU alum and a civil and
environmental engineering graduate
although Jim at that time was it
environmental it was just civil and dr.
Robert Morris who's been a longtime
friend and acquaintance of us and I'll
come back to them in just a second I
just want to say a few words about the
relationship with IBM which has been
long and distinguished and it's very
appropriate and we're very excited to
have the opportunity to help IBM
celebrate its hundred years as a
corporate leader with this program in
lecture there have been a number of
really notable innovations that have
come out of Carnegie Mellon's work with
IBM over the years in the 1980s we
worked together on what was at the time
a very ambitious prototype for a
computing environment which is the
environment that we've become so used to
that project led to the creation of the
Andrew computing network and CMU became
the first university with a completely
wired campus although IBM might be
saying the same thing so it was us at
IBM I guess that were at the forefront
of of that together with IBM we also
continue to advance question and answer
technologies and natural language
processing and this joint research is
likely to be as transformative as the
Andrew networking project was in pushing
the capabilities of the technology
beyond even what we know it to be today
we marked a historic moment in the
research when IBM's soup supercomputer
Watson made its first appearance at a
university and went up against students
from CMU and the University of
Pittsburgh and the game of Jeopardy on
our campus in February I guess even
before the National Jeopardy show
and more recently we've been working
with IBM as part of its smarter planet
initiative to create technologies to
help cities governments and industries
worldwide to develop smarter
infrastructure and the IBM Smarter
infrastructure lab is part of the
Pennsylvania smart infrastructure
incubator here at CMU in addition to our
joint research efforts with the company
IBM supports CMU and many other ways as
well that I'm very pleased to recognize
the company provides generous and direct
support to our faculty and to our
students and is a very strong recruiter
of our graduates there are currently
more than 500 CMU alumni who are
employed at IBM and I believe that there
are over 40 faculty and students across
campus at this very moment who've been
receiving benefits and financial support
from IBM so we're very very grateful and
hope the partnership continues to thrive
on both sides in the future now to say
briefly a few words about our presenters
Wayne is a corporate vice president of
vice president of corporate
environmental affairs and product safety
at IBM his a leadership was recently
recognized as he IBM was just recently
listed as number one on Newsweek who
screen rankings of America's largest
public companies and number two globally
Wayne also serves on the president's
advisory board for civil and
environmental engineering here at CMU
and on the Dean's Advisory Council for
CIT dr. Robert Morris is an old friend
of Carnegie Mellon we I first met him I
think some five or six years ago on
various visits here in addition to being
vice president of all of IBM Research
Robert has also chosen to sign on in the
past as the executive of at IBM who's
assigned to CMU and in that capacity
he's been CMU's official champion at IBM
globally and has been instrumental in
expanding our partnership and we again
look forward to continued his continued
leadership and working together as we
pursue the smarter planet initiative so
it's my great pleasure to turn over the
podium to Wayne Ball death Wing
thank you and I am indeed very pleased
to be back here at Carnegie Mellon it's
an institution for which I have the
deepest respect
it's a world-renowned institution that's
recognized far and wide for excellence
an institution which has already infused
much innovation into the world but which
yet still majors to this day on
inspiring innovation so I am indeed very
honored to be here today to speak with
you about IBM's centennial and first
hundred years in business this year does
mark IBM's 100th anniversary that's a
remarkable milestone to reach no one
else in our industry sector has managed
it and only a few enterprises of any
kind have now we don't view this only as
an occasion to celebrate our past but
instead we are looking ahead and
thinking hard about what our hundred
year history tells us about the world
today and tomorrow most importantly we
want to engage with existing leaders
like you and many future leaders here in
the audience today to share our
perspectives and understanding about
what individuals and institutions need
to do to succeed in today's globally
integrating technology infused world we
believe these insights are important for
anyone in a leadership position and
these insights will be especially
critical to the next generation of
leaders and forward thinkers who are now
charting their own paths as global
citizens based on IBM's experience over
a hundred years I believe I believe one
challenge we will all face at one time
or another is how to reinvent your
organization whether that organization
is a business an arm of government or in
fact a university we've learned that
institutions are not permanent
structures even when they're successful
for a time rather they're evolving
organisms and the job of each generation
is to adapt them to a continually
changing
so let me begin the lecture with two
questions first what enables a company
to survive for 100 years and second even
more important how can it remain a
leader for such a long time if we go
back to the Year 1962 in 1962 Thomas
Watson jr. IBM's chairman and the son of
the company's founder stood before a
lectern at another great university
Columbia University in New York City and
he addressed an audience of future
leaders at that time IBM had recently
turned 50 years old and mr. Watson was
invited to offer his thoughts on what
half a century of corporate life had
taught his company than what other
leaders might learn from that and mr.
Watson began his remarks with a striking
statistic he said that up the top 25
corporations in the United States as of
1900 the only two had remained on that
list in 1960 to the time of his lecture
and he said figures like these help to
remind us that corporations are
expendable and that success at best is
an impermanent achievement which can
always slip out of hand now here we are
50 years later after Tom Watson's
lecture at Columbia and IBM is
celebrating its centennial so what have
100 years of history taught us well one
thing they've taught us is that mr.
Watson was right success is fleeting
because of the top 25 companies on the
fortune 500 at the time of Watson's
lecture 1962 only six remained as of the
year 2010 more importantly though the
last 50 years have taught us about
taught us something about how any
business or institution can achieve
continued success and impact and it's
really quite simple long-term success is
the product of managing for the long
term now of course everyone pays lip
service to that but really taking it
seriously
means some clearly identifiable
behaviors and choices and IBM's
experience through a half century of
corporate life provides some valuable
lessons in its practice I believe three
lessons in particular are of special
urgency for the world's leaders of
tomorrow to inherit and to decisions
they'll need to make for their own
organizations and communities first how
an organization must change as the world
economy changes second how an
organization must change in response to
changes in technology and third how the
organization must actually remain the
same at its core in the face of a
changing world so let me briefly touch
on each first how an organization must
adapt as a world economy changes I think
the single most important reality facing
business in institutions today is the
reality of global integration of course
the world has been going global for a
long time that's nothing new but what
this means in each successive era can be
different being a global corporation
today is very different from what it was
when IBM was founded a hundred years ago
from the time he arrived at a company
named CTR IBM's predecessor way back in
the year 1914
Tom Watson senior believed that
globalization was inevitable he was
convinced that an integrated world
economy was the future and indeed it was
the key to world peace now that latter
hope remains obviously unfulfilled so
far but IBM's mindset has been global
from the start through most of the 20th
century that meant becoming what
economic historians would later come to
call a multinational in this model the
parent corporation created many versions
of itself in country after country in
order to be able to operate amid the
crazy quilt of regulations and trade
barriers IBM itself was one of the best
examples of the mid century
multinational but all that began to
change in the 1980s and 90s with the
lowering of trade barriers and
especially the emergence of the
worldwide
as a result massive global rebalancing
is now underway in part this is about
the world becoming smarter and flatter
global as global integration is creating
new economic opportunity most
importantly through hundreds of millions
of people around the world entering the
middle class they're becoming
consultants and entrepreneurs and this
is a macro economic fact of historic
proportion but this shift is also
changing how we work the form and
operation of all organizations
established businesses and startups
large corporations and local shops as
well as governments communities and
universities are changing and are likely
going to have to change a lot more
global integration is forcing us once
again to reset our worldview and to
rethink how we see our role in that
world because we at IBM believed this
shift was inevitable we transformed IBM
over the last decade from the old
multinational model to something new
something more systemic which we call
the globally integrated enterprise ok
this is not only changing the market
opportunities we pursue but also the way
we work and run the company from sales
and marketing to HR and research we've
moved expertise and decision-making out
of corporate headquarters today IBM's
operations are in fact globally
integrated and network for example our
procurement function is headquartered in
China we have dozens in a dozens of
research labs around the world for which
my colleague here today Robert Morris is
directly responsible Robert himself sits
in Shanghai China we've also changed our
understanding of the skills
relationships and responsibilities that
idea MERS must assume to make this
integration work let me give you an
example that encompasses all of these
shifts in the area of leadership
development in the multinational era you
prepared Future Leaders through overseas
- typically for two years and typically
in mature markets as a management
development system it was expensive and
limited in scope to a handful of
executives but today those multinational
approaches no longer work we need to
create a whole generation of global
professionals and global citizens and
the model of overseas assignments I
described that won't scale to that so
three years ago we launched an
experiment we call corporate service
core it puts together diverse teams of
high potential ideas from around the
world and sends them as a team for a
month to communities and cities in
emerging markets places such as gone in
the Philippines Thailand turkey Vietnam
they work in communities with NGOs and
local leaders to jumpstart economies and
to make the cities smarter and when they
come back they spread what they have
learned to their IBM colleagues directly
and through social media the results so
far this has been highly encouraging not
only are we able to provide this
experience to more IBM a--'s thousands
rather than dozens but these targeted
interventions are having a
transformative impact both on local
communities and on the IBM errs
themselves most say it's one of the most
Amin 'uncle experiences they've had in
their career at the same time it's
helping us as a company gather
invaluable learning about reality on the
ground in these emerging markets it is
strengthening IBM societal relationships
and it's surfacing profitable new
business opportunities as I said the
world's been going global for centuries
but that will mean very different things
in the 21st century than it meant in the
20th to be a leader in the future will
mean thinking globally seeing as a
planet as a whole and that's not just
about geography which leads me to lesson
two that is the role of technology for
today's leaders now it's widely accepted
that major shifts in technology have had
a
profound impact on the course of history
and on the form of human organizations
we can look back to the invention of the
tools of agriculture and how that
enabled humans to live in cities we can
look at the technologies invented by the
Romans and by the Chinese which enabled
the emergence of great empires and in
the modern era we can look to the impact
of the technologies that spawned the Age
of Discovery and the Industrial
Revolution over the course of the last
century I would submit to you that the
most profound impact has come from
information technology we've seen it
evolved from a set of tools to an
industry to a science to a pervasive
aspect of the modern world through this
era IT has become much more than a
back-office engine or a never-ending
flow of consumer gadgets it has become
something that every leader must master
and I don't mean learning how to tweet
or how to use an iPad okay
technology is now the way we see the
world including those dimensions
invisible to the human eye it's how we
map and understand the dynamics of the
world's complex systems and it's
increasingly how we decide upon the best
course of action and actually put it
into effect indeed technology now it
pervades every aspect of the way our
world works the systems and processes
that enable services to be delivered
physical goods to be developed
manufactured and sold everything from
people and freight to oil water and
electrons to move and billions of people
to work and live today there are nearly
a billion transistors per human and each
one costs one ten-millionth of a cent
we note there are four billion mobile
phone subscribers 30 billion RFID tags
produced globally these sensors and
devices give us for the first time ever
real-time instrumentation of the world's
systems both natural systems and
man-made systems
but the planet isn't just instrumented
it's also interconnected today there are
two billion people on the internet but
systems and objects can now speak to one
another as well okay that's what some
call the Internet of Things think about
the prospect of a trillion connected and
instrumented objects cars cameras
roadways pipelines even livestock and
pharmaceuticals all of this is creating
vast amounts of data and through
advanced analytics and ever more
powerful supercomputers we can turn that
data into insight all over the world we
see forward-thinking leaders who are
mastering these new capabilities and to
no one's surprise in this audience we
see that happening across Carnegie
Mellon witnesses Provost camlet said the
new Pennsylvania smart infrastructure
incubator and our establishment of the
IBM Smarter infrastructure lab here at
Carnegie Mellon ok that you miss this
you missed this phenomena if you see
technology merely as a succession of
gadgets websites and next big things ok
what IBM's history has taught us is that
it's much more gadgets come and go and
they inevitably become commodities but
the deeper role of information
technology as a science is a pervasive
fact of the way our world works
that something leaders have an
obligation to understand not as
mechanics but its implications I'm proud
to say iBM has been a leader in just
about every dimension of I t's evolution
we started off making clocks scales and
believe it or not cheese slicers ok in
addition to the punch card tabulating
but we never identified our purpose with
one product or one technology true we
invented and applied a remarkable
succession of them typewriters vacuum
tube calculators magnetic tape the first
disk drive the memory chip Fortran ATMs
mainframes many computers personal
computers and supercomputers today we
still provide many of those along with
advanced services software and analytics
but some of them we don't and that's
also about reinvention for example when
we introduced when we introduced the IBM
PC in 1981 and the very popular think
pad laptop in 1992 it was by any measure
the most recognizable brand for us and
arguably the only brand that touched
individuals tens of millions of people
for all those reasons the idea that we
would divest sell that PC business was
for many pardon the pun unthinkable yet
we knew the emerging computing model I
just described to only accelerate the
commoditization of the PC industry and
that's not where we want it to be given
the continual flow of technological
prowess forward motion is the only way
for a tech company to stay out of
commodity hell so we decided our PC
business would have a better future in
the hands of another company which
turned out to be Lenovo we are
innovators in 1981 the PC was an
innovation 20 years later it lost me
much of its differentiation it was time
to move on to the future we're entering
a very different world we can only begin
to see the challenges will face in the
years to come
future leaders will need to understand
and grapple with the new issues this
information era will present and work to
keep moving our organizations and
systems into the future which brings me
to lesson three regarding how an
organization retains its distinctive
core through continual change okay think
about my last two remarks about changing
in response to economy and technology
and now to talk a little bit about
remaining the same at your core you know
perhaps Thomas Watson's seniors most
enduring contribution to the world was
the notion that an organization can and
must undertake the intentional creation
of its culture of course every
organization city or community has a
culture usually defined as that's the
way we do things
here okay it's often an extension of the
organization's founder his or her
beliefs actions decision or personality
now there's no question that the cult of
personality in business is a very
powerful lure the idea of the
charismatic superstar leader the press
cultivates
Wall Street trades on it some employees
craven tom watson senior himself was an
example of it but what happens when the
founder is no longer around okay
the challenge becomes how to perpetuate
culture through time that's hard for a
century that's really hard how do you
bottle up what makes an organization
distinct what makes IBM IBM what makes
the Pittsburgh Steelers the Pittsburgh
Steelers
what makes Carnegie Mellon Carnegie
Mellon and how do you make that a
lasting foundation for your
organization's culture okay 50 years ago
in his lectures at Columbia Tom Watson
jr. located the vitality of an
organization's culture not in rituals
like team-building exercises or company
songs even though IBM did those things
and more but rather had its shared
values or beliefs and here's what he
said let me quote I firmly believe that
any organization in order to survive and
achieve success must have a sound set of
beliefs on which it premises all its
policies and actions next I believe that
the most important single factor in
corporate success is the faithful
adherence to those beliefs and finally I
believe that if an organization is to
meet the challenges of a changing world
it must be prepared to change everything
about itself accept those beliefs as it
moves through corporate life so let me
repeat that last line be prepared to
change everything about itself accept
those beliefs
now Tom Watson was not talking about
moral precepts not about legal
compliance or ethical behavior every
organization an individual needs to do
that for him and the IBM company beliefs
were about its identity what makes it
distinct what shapes its decision
decision-making processes and behaviors
if you could codify and sustain that
core it would ensure that the company
remains unique and differentiated decade
after decade time has taught us how
essential this is how it can go awry and
how we have to continually revisit it
and recontextualize it for new
generations in fact I would argue that
the need for this foundation is greater
today than ever before in a globalizing
world with work spread across vast
networks of organizations and
individuals people need something that
holds them together okay a touchstone
for their actions and for their
decisions that's why we decided nearly a
decade ago that if IBM was going to
return to greatness in a new era
it required getting back in touch with
our own DNA one of the first things our
current chairman and chief executive Sam
Palmisano did as CEO was to initiate an
effort to re-examine our core values but
he didn't do it in the traditional way
we no longer live in a world where the
Chairman can simply lay out a company's
basic beliefs
hey iBM is there a super smart bunch of
people and smart people today tend to be
independent even a bit cynical
you don't come down from on high and
tell them these are your values so we
took a different approach we examined
and re articulated IBM's basic beliefs
through a provocative social media
experiment in fact at a time before
there were things called social media
experiments in a process we called
values Jim and short as a company we
came together online as a global
population over 72 hours and we hash
this out it was messy passionate
contentious but the values that a word
emerged were not IBM's values they were
IBM ours values and they ended up being
dedication to every client success
innovation that matters for our company
and for the world and Trust and personal
responsibility in our relationships now
we've done a lot of work since then we
have globally integrated our company
we've also remade IBM
portfolio of products and services
including as I said the divestiture of
our PC business and that decision which
could have caused a rift inside the
company was instead embraced not merely
on the basis of economics and strategy
but because it was consistent with our
values indeed I believe none of these
changes would have been effective or
sustainable if we had not first gone
back to basics back to our roots back to
the foundation of our culture and
brought it alive for the current era
IBM's history in fact can be seen as a
century long experiment in how to
institutionalize and perpetuate what
makes us us and for any of you in the
audience who will be among the next
January
generation of leaders and I see many I
would suggest that this will be your
most fundamental task no matter what
kind of work organization or community
you wind up leading now if you followed
me so far you might agree that the world
today finds itself at an inflection
point in the evolution and application
of technology and the continuing march
of global integration and in the ways we
manage and sustain our institutions I
believe we're also at an inflection
point in the ways we manage and sustain
our planet let me speak for a moment
about this latter point our planet or
environmental sustainability since that
involves my own direct area of
responsibility at IBM over the past five
to six years environmental
sustainability has exploded in
popularity it's now implanted in the
minds of many forward-thinking leaders
no matter what aspect of business
government or society they serve but to
be realistic it hasn't always been this
way the broad popularity of
environmental sustainability has in fact
been cyclical for since the first Earth
Day back in 1970 and so if the
sustainability of our planet is indeed a
future imperative the relevant question
for any organization is how do you
sustain sustainability over the long
term when the topic may temporarily fall
off the cover of
mainstream media after all it's easy to
be green when everyone's watching the
real leadership involves what you do
when no one's watching well for global
institutions at large I must say I'm
personally very encouraged that's
because the next generation of young
people some of whom may be here is far
more passionate about environmental
sustainability than any other in recent
memory it's gone from theory to fact
we're on the front edge of a new wave of
leaders that want to perform work that
not only delivers a return to
shareholders but want to perform work
that's good for society a generation
that thinks not just about stockholders
but also about stakeholders in regarding
the IBM company I must say I'm
personally very proud to have this
responsibility because IBM's the company
that has consistently practiced
environmental leadership regardless of
its popularity and regardless regardless
of the company's short-term financial
results we spoke earlier about Tom
Watson jr. well he also had something
forward-looking to say about in brahmano
responsibilities 40 years ago he
established a formal corporate policy on
this subject here's what he said he said
line management in IBM must be
continuously on guard against adversely
affecting the environment this effort
must include constant attention not only
to the waste incident to producing the
product but also to the consequences of
the processes established during product
development now there's three notable
things about this first Watson wrote it
in May 1971 which is of course the year
our federal government first created the
Environmental Protection Agency second
Watson wasn't talking about having some
staff people worry about the environment
he pinned responsibility right online
management where it belongs and third
Watson didn't just acknowledge the need
to address waste he was talking about
preventing pollution from the very
beginning of the design process
it was very forward-looking indeed back
in 1971 today IBM managers and
environmental sustainability as a
strategic imperative we make
forward-looking decisions based on
science
facts we work to anticipate
opportunities and prevent problems our
work is anchored in a single global
environmental management system it
integrates roles and responsibilities
throughout the business we said
measurable goals achieve demonstrable
results and publicly disclosed them in
fact iBM has published 21 consecutive
annual corporate environmental reports
in a row
uninterrupted going back to 1990 that's
longer than any other company in the
world we know of and I think it says
something about sustaining
sustainability
looking ahead were committed for the
long term and this I submit is
characteristic of any organization which
endeavors to be around for the next 100
years
okay underlying this conviction is a
conviction underlying this commitment is
a conviction the conviction is good
environmental management makes good
business sense like other leading
companies we've observed this time and
again okay to give a portion of the
examples would constitute a whole
separate lecture maybe even a college
course right so let me just cite three
quick ones first involves energy
conservation between 1990 and 2010 IBM
is conserved over 5.4 billion kilowatt
hours of electricity
warded over three and a half million
tons of co2 emissions and save 400
million dollars of direct expense it's a
lot of money the business impact is
obvious the stature that comes with it
is also advantageous for instance IBM
received the u.s. EPA's climate
protection award in that programs very
first year 1998 and earned it again in
2006 making IBM the first company in any
industry sector to earn it twice and as
Provost Kamla mentioned just earlier
this week on Monday Newsweek magazine
ranked IBM the number one company on its
list of meanest companies in the US
second example involves product
development back in 1991
IBM established the IT industry's first
formal design for the environment
program not long thereafter in the early
nineties IBM enabled another
forward-thinking
institution Carnegie Mellon University
to launch what's now known as the Green
Design Institute spanning the College of
Engineering and The Temper School of
Business third example would involve a
company's supply chain of how good
Environmental Management makes good
business sense okay
our history includes many interventions
to work with suppliers who perform in a
responsible manner
we had the IBM supplier conduct
principles in 2004 and just last year in
2010 we began requiring now all of IBM's
global suppliers to do three things
establish and deploy their own
environmental management system said at
least three voluntary goals and measure
results and publicly disclose their
performance we did this because we want
our suppliers to succeed when they
succeed we succeed and for them to be
long-term winners they need to build
their own capacity to manage the topic
of environmental sustainability
so all these brief measures I've
described make good business sense for
IBM they all occurred before and
regardless of any law or regulation and
they all represent the type of corporate
responsibility that will differentiate
leading companies from an endangered
species not just a hundred years from
now but ten years from now but there's a
second facet to this that's even more
important and it's opportune for
tomorrow's leaders it derives from the
manner in which environmental policy is
evolving and what technology and a
systemic approach towards business now
make possible the environmental movement
modern day got started in the early 70s
with a focus on controlling pollution
that was occurring and you had certain
landmark federal statutes that
transformed through the 80s and 90s from
a control centric mentality to one
that's prevention centric and you had
acts like the US pollution prevention
act and European Union directive
regarding hazardous substances well
following these eras of control and
prevention we are now at the dawn of a
new era for environmental sustainability
that of innovation and the era of
innovation is a little different because
it offers anticipation and opportunity
not reaction
and constraint and it comes at a time
when what we used to call third world
countries are rapidly developing from
where I sit institutions of all kinds
are ready to capitalize on new
analytical insights from our ability to
instrument and interconnect the world
today's leaders are blazing the trail of
what we at IBM call a smarter planet one
that's more efficient and more
sustainable and it's not just happening
in the developing world or the developed
world the emerging markets are hungry
for innovation that will enable them to
grow their economies and protect their
environments in ways that are not solely
a function of law and regulation they're
ready to move because this kind of
innovation delivers value and
competitive advantage so when we rolled
out smarter planet we said the way the
world works isn't smart enough to be
sustainable but that's the kind of Grand
Challenge that energizes IBM people
we're integrating expertise and
technology with business across diverse
sectors for innovation that matters
consistent with our core values
we're relentlessly pursuing innovation
that the delivers value because that's
how we sustain sustainability ok heading
towards the close here that's good
because the real key precondition for
change now exists people who want change
and they're hungry for leadership these
kind of moments don't come around often
perhaps every decade or every few times
a century and it won't last forever ok
those who seize that today are the
leaders of tomorrow I'm convinced that
forward-thinking individuals communities
companies and countries around the world
can build a smarter more secure more
sustainable planet so in closing let me
suggest that the measure of any great
entity business government university or
other institution is ultimately what was
its impact how was the world different
because it existed and it's really quite
simple an organization won't change the
world if it itself
can't survive change as I've said
long-term success is the product of
managing for the long term
and I believe that managing for the long
term comes down most fundamentally to an
enduring and evolving identity or
culture grounded in core values I admit
to a bias of course but I believe the
past century has been better because of
IBM and I'm confident that the next one
can be - I also like to think that we
will still show up near the top of the
fortune 500 for the Year 2060 one in the
year 2011
well that will conclude my planned
remarks for today I hope you share my
excitement about the opportunities
before all of us I look forward to some
questions discussion with you and the
like and for that my colleague Robert
Morris vice president of service
research and global research labs will
join me to entertain your questions and
discussion thank you what's on your
minds in the back
mobilization by a centralized
well and then we said that
was tightening up in Vegas and causation
was good I hear time that be centralized
those letters
and so at the time we were a moulting we
our business was a multinational
business model we created many replicas
of ourself in different countries around
the world because 50 years ago
mid-century that was a sensible way to
earn business and have impact around the
world partly in recognition of trade
barriers and restriction and regulators
of the era but as the world has as the
economy has globalized and as the world
has become as it's been said more flat
and as opportunities increased we
recognized that that sort of
multinational dispersed model no longer
would work and that's when we created
what we now call the globally integrated
enterprise so I would suggest I mean the
way we call it inside of IBM isn't
necessarily centralized integrated ok is
the operative work and we integrate
skills and capabilities across the world
based on where skills and capabilities
exist and we find ourselves able to
deploy those skills for whatever market
opportunity to present themselves while
also enabling us to respond as a
business to the current 24/7 global
nature of Commerce and that model of
going from multinational to globally
integrated where we have was a couple of
examples I gave you located key
functions around the world is very
important as Robert could tell you ok in
Shanghai China that's where we have the
headquarters for our business and over a
hundred and thirty countries ok and in
New York we have the headquarters for
our businesses in about 30 countries ok
that's a reflection of the way the world
is globalizing and integrating anything
you want to add right ok thank you
as you look ahead I wonder what IBM is
thinking about the future looking for
seeds runs a product stewardship so in
New York part of it drove the engagement
below three designs to hear thinking
about product feedback for computers and
missed some progress in Europe a little
bit in the u.s. many countries not on
the horizon but going ahead thinking
about corporate responsibility for the
product from its creation to its end use
and we're using it before for everything
your product line you might even look
like you know beyond IBM where you see
the trance culture and I think market or
shares or overall product
responsibilities okay I think an initial
response toward waste management and
recycling is what one would naturally
expect to occur and it did just in the
same way I told you about the evolution
of the environmental movement from
control to prevention to innovation
there's an analogy here as well I would
say Dave that one of the most
interesting opportunities in front of us
involves traceability okay in this
regard so you asked about product
stewardship going forward traceability
which is enabled by the kind of
innovation we're talking about in IBM is
something that will matter to all
industry sectors not just the
electronics or IT industry sector in
fact Robert you and I were chatting
about this a little bit during lunch
today if you think about how
transparency has changed across
societies thanks again to a world wide
web and the accessibility of information
by many okay one can foresee quickly a
time when the traceability of materials
are substances in goods or services
becomes of critical importance for
success and pick an industry sector okay
you can you can look at unintended
kademan earrings unintended contaminants
and pharmaceuticals
now sulfurous gases embedded unknown
million drywall melamine and milk okay
mad cow okay picket whether it's
pharmaceutical agriculture retail the
traceability materials in response to
your question about product stewardship
I see that as an area ripe for
innovation and able to by today's
technology and business process yes sir
that's years what do you think well we
had a near failure in the early 1990s I
mean Robert and I and other IBM errs
here who were managers can can recall
managing through it Robert maybe this is
when you want to comment so we learned a
lot from mistakes and I'll just I'll
just pick one to talk about which was we
didn't realize the changes that were
taking place in the world of software
and systems so at a time when we you
could say we mishandled the PC business
in many ways we invented it but we ceded
the control of the microprocessor in the
operating system to another company to
to other companies we we this this was a
mistake and we aren't up to it and we've
tried to learn from it and we realized
from that there were two things first of
all we had ceded control but we also
realized that situations had been
created which actually were not
beneficial to our clients because we had
individual entities who were basically
exerting architectural control and so we
adopted a different strategy which is we
said we will fundamentally support open
interfaces in the stack of information
technology meaning that by all means any
one company can provide a piece of
technology but the interfaces should
always be open and therefore these
various technologies should be pluggable
so you should have a choice of micro
processes you should have a choice of
operating systems and we began to
actually disassemble some of the
vertical integration that we had on just
take you for exactly for example disk
drive we also invented the disk drive
and subsequently we also divested the
disk drive but there was a very
interesting era in that time when our
our advantage in the district came from
the disk drive head however we decided
we would sell the disk drive head to
anyone else who wanted to integrate so
if you take this approach that you're
willing to decomp onin ties and always
give your clients a choice and never try
to control anything through an
architectural control point everyone
will be better because will be selected
where we're stronger and will be free to
use the components of someone else where
they're stronger and we will never be
locked into this vertical integration
this was a huge learning for us it
caused us to we we caused us to embrace
to look at the open-source movement and
we participate in a great deal of
open-source today it caused us to
embrace linux as an operating system and
we run linux on many of our platforms we
also run certain proprietary operating
systems which we do for various reasons
of providing great degrees of security
for banks and so on which linux can't
provide but that we fully embrace open
source we fully embrace open interfaces
and we're where possible we always
promote open interfaces so people can
assemble components and nobody exerts an
architectural control point because we
believe it's not good for our clients
remember the first value that when when
when talked about the three values the
first one is basically the client the
value of the client preserve the value
of the client and do everything in the
interest of the value of clients so
trying to exert a control or a monopoly
it's not in the interest of our clients
is not in the interest of our industry
not in the interest area so that was a
huge change and it only happened 20
years ago but we've grown and we've
behaved in that way since then and it's
actually been to our great benefit
and learning in our lifetimes everybody
and if you stay focused on the client
the three values they produce on the
client you stay focused on innovation
and always doing new things and not
being stuck in the past and the third
thing you stay focused on personal
responsibility and integrity you'll be
all right that's out that those were the
values that we try to spare I think we
have time for once we break up I'll be
able to research based questions Robert
what I what I would tell you okay what I
what I would say is is consider IBM's
transformation right and consider where
we were how we've adapted and most
importantly why and if a university
finds that its constituents are global
in character and that global economies
in their integration matter greatly to
the university's fundamental mission of
research and education and I would think
it could indeed make sense to understand
how does the long-established
institution of academia adapt to these
changes that we discussed specifically
globalizing economies and what
information technology makes possible
okay you've been very kind to pay
attention for a good while I thank you
greatly I wish everyone a terrific rest
of the afternoon thank you